i know dr peterson the the amazing man
that stands before me today but i i want
to know who
jordan was at at 16 years old so so if
you were to go back in time to you know
fairview and alberta who was jordan
peterson at 16 years old what was that
guy like
well
i didn't care much for school i wouldn't
say
although
younger than that i was younger than
that when i took my first university
course i was just remembering that this
year there was a professor named dennis
wheeler who taught at this local college
it was about 90 miles away
and he was interested in distance
education he came up north to our little
town
and taught a course on political science
which i took when i was 14 and i really
liked that so there was some
aspects of academic pursuit that i loved
and i read a lot i pretty much read a
book a day from the time i was about 10
until
well
till i started reading really serious
books and couldn't read one of those in
a day
so for years you know and
i had a it was a working-class place and
all my friends pretty much were
working-class kids most of them dropped
out of school in grade 9 or grade 10
and then went off to work on the oil
rigs that
where they could make a fortune
especially for someone that young
i worked from the time i was 14 onward i
worked in restaurants
and i liked that a lot i worked first as
a dishwasher which was an impossible job
for me to begin with um until the german
chef took pity on me and showed me how
to do it after i struggled away for
about three weeks like swamped by dishes
but i like that because i was treated
like an adult and i really appreciated
that and i worked i had a bit of a
political
interest
well more than a bit at that point i i
worked for a local our local member of
the legislative assembly at the
provincial level so that's the state
level for you american types and
i was interested in socialist ideas at
that point and
that lasted that
that political interest of that precise
sort lasted till i was about
17 i would say when i realized that i
just didn't know anything and that a
political career at that point which was
something that was open to me in a
strange way
that would have that was radically
premature
so
that was me at 16 i would say
i do that i was in grade 12 then i went
i went to college when i was 17. left
home when i was 17.
oh wow
so um
so you went to college when you were 17
years old so 16 years old
you were it was very annoying because i
couldn't get in the bar
it was very annoying because all my
friends would go to the bar and
sometimes even classes were held there
and i couldn't go and i looked like i
was like 13 so
there was no way i was sneaking in
so
and and what did you do undergraduate um
dr peterson
i did two years at this local college
grand prairie regional college and it
was in a beautiful building designed by
a native canadian architect named
douglas cardinal it was his first major
commission it was an outstanding
building absolutely beautiful curved
brick on the outside
no no square corners beautiful white
rounded interior
and um
i had great professors there i had i
i it's so interesting as i was just
writing about that this week i had six
professors there
that were outstanding one in biology
political science
english literature history
art
um
who else was there i didn't name all six
but that's close and they were
all men as it turned out
and they were really deeply committed to
teaching the english profession
professor robin burke
um
he i think he gave me like a three out
of nine on my first essay which just
shocked the hell out of me yeah it was
quite the shock because i thought i
could write i got good grades in high
school despite not doing any work and
i'd never really run into someone who
could actually write and he could write
and i couldn't at all and so he taught
me he was a tough guy and and you know a
strict guy but
my friends and i loved him and i was so
fortunate because i i got together with
a good group of friends some couple of
them came with me from fairview
and we all sat together in in these
classes and so i had a really good
social life there
um our whole little cadre took over the
student union
the second year i was at this little
college and
we ran a huge surplus which was the
first time that ever happened i we
couldn't figure out how you could
possibly run a deficit at a student
government when you could
hold dances and sell beer to
undergraduates it's like how can you not
make a profit doing that
anyways it was a blast and i got a
really good education there for two
years and then i went to the university
of alberta
for a year and finished my bachelor's
degree and that was political science
with a minor in english
and you could get a three-year degree at
that point and then i worked for no i
yeah i worked on road crews for six
months and then went to europe for four
months and then i went to
university again for a year because i
decided that i was going to study
psychology so i took nothing but
psychology courses for a whole year and
got a second ba
you know not exactly but that's how it
worked and then i worked for another
year and then i went to graduate school
so that was that was that was all that
so would you say majority of your
friends
were working in the oil rigs or would
you say majority of your friends went on
to college with you oh no no no hardly
anyone from my graduating class went on
to college there was me and
a handful of other people virtually
everyone stayed in in this town
and most you know i had different
friends somewhat different friends in
high school than i did in junior high
because junior high was grade seven to
nine because so many of my previous
friends had
dropped out of school and so and then a
new crowd came in these were kids that
were
they lived in an even more remote place
called bear canyon which was literally
on the edge of the prairie frontier like
and and there was no high school there
so they came to as residents they they
had to live with families and they were
they stayed in school though those three
characters i'm still in touch with all
three of them they were great friends of
mine and
one of them came to college with me and
was a roommate for a while and but i
but that was it most people didn't go no
yeah
so do you feel as though
you were
a um
a individual who was moving to the beat
of your own drum
and had more of a leader disposition
because it would appear that if you're
in an environment where all your other
peers are not interested in going to
school there could be easy proclivity
for an individual to not desire to go to
school as well and to you know chase
some money during the oil rig so what
was it inside of you that made you be
able to you know still desire to pass
higher education though everybody else
is moving in a different direction
well my parents were both university
educated and so my dad was a teacher
he's still alive
and my mom was a nurse
they had both left the small town they
were from in saskatchewan it was an even
smaller town and and gone to university
and it was just expected in our house i
never questioned it i knew
i knew from the time i was 11
10 that i was going to leave fairview
and and and pursue my education i didn't
know how far and at that point i didn't
understand the tiers of higher education
you know bachelor masters phd
um but i knew and you know it was
interesting because
virtually everyone i knew that did leave
that little town
knew that they were going to leave when
they were that young
and so it's hard to tell why these
things happen i wouldn't say that it was
precisely i wouldn't say that it was
because i was a leader exactly because
my friends weren't followers
none of them including the kids who
went off to work on the oil rigs those
kids were tough man and part of the
reason they quit school is because they
got sick and tired of putting up their
hands to ask to go to the bathroom when
they were you know pretty much men and
they were men enough to go work on the
rigs so
so no i wasn't leading them i was small
and
because i'd skipped a grade
so i was younger than everyone else in
my class and i was rather small for my
age anyways and so
i was surrounded by guys generally who
had a lot more physical prowess than me
i didn't really participate in
team sports until i went to graduate
school
partly because of that reason although i
went skiing with my my father and cross
country skiing and trapping and that and
and hunting and that sort of thing
so
um but i was much more academically
inclined than most of my friends and
i wasn't exactly from the same kind of
working-class background that they were
from so most of my friends their parents
had
finished high school or not um
i had one friend who whose parents were
university educated
and he did go to college but he never he
never continued he had he had some
pretty severe mental health problems
unfortunately
um so um how many siblings did you have
two i had a i have a younger sister
she's a year and a half younger than me
bonnie and i have a
brother who's four and a half years
younger than me jewel
[Music]
[Music]
mmm
[Music]
[Music]
you